the heart of the French capital Paris
man just a few steps from the Arc de
Triomphe I've got an appointment to meet
and Rico Bernardo in his gourmet
restaurant el vino the Italian opened a
business in 2007 three years after he
was first featured on euromaxx flash
back to our 2004 report back then we met
Enrico Bernardo at the Paris luxury
hotel george sang where he was dead some
of the a he had just been voted world's
best sommelier a day before making him
the youngest winner ever at the age of
27 but henrico Bernardo was already
looking ahead to even bigger goals how
important was it to you to to win that
title for your career my professional
life change for sure I opened my first
dress on second dress on third
restaurant the wine shop now and I did
many consulting around the world I
design glasses of wines this title can
change your life
today Enrico Bernardo is going to show
me his culinary Paris our first stop a
market on President Wilson Avenue we're
together with the chef from his newest
restaurant we're scouting for top
quality ingredients Joe LTA bows herb
and vegetable stand is a reliable source
his products are grown on a field just
10 kilometers away from the Eiffel Tower
how easy is it to to get good
ingredients here in Paris if you if you
work well it's not so complicated you
need to find the right people example
these guys he know where every history
of every each vegetable you can tell
this is a true bitter this one is more
spicy he is the star of the vegetable in
France yeah for sure to back with
ingredients in hand we head to enrico
Bernardo's third restaurant boost
walking is his favorite way to get
around town with its world-famous sites
Paris draws some 29 million visitors
every year Bernardo has been living in
Paris for 15 years but he still marbles
at the buildings around him like the
Grand Palais museum and the plaza
vendome with its late 17th century
neoclassical architecture and Rico
Bernardo opened goosed in March and
already the restaurant is considered a
likely candidate for a Michelin star
we sample our way through the menu
accompanied by just the right wine for
every course on average Bernardo drinks
a bottle of wine a day half a bottle for
lunch another half at dinner afterward
he wants to show me his favorite bar on
the way there we passed the Louvre one
of the world's premier art museums and
stroll along the send the wine bars
juvenille and it's Scottish owner Tim
Johnston Bernardo met Johnston had a
vineyard in Australia this bar is where
he honed his skills for blindfold taste
testing ahead of the sommelier of the
Year competition is a special place and
for sure it was pledged special in this
period of my life that there was so
young and they prepare this competition
came here with the person with a lot of
experience like team and with the
beautiful wine selection now we're
walking through the San German
neighborhood it was once the haunt of
Paris intellectuals now it's a trendy
district
it's also home to bernardos wine shop
champion once or twice a year he gives
seminars that span several days on
proper wine sampling I got a condensed
version of the course and I practice
with a 2006 Bordeaux the first thing is
to examine the wines clarity and color
next comes the swirl to observe the
wines viscosity or alcohol and sugar
content then a sniff to prepare for the
taste experience an elegant red wine but
you don't drink it any old way little
bit like that why because when you the
oxygen going the mouth Alwine start to
go in in each place of your palate and
you can feel all sensation back at el
vino and Rico Bernardo explains the
restaurants concept to me every dish is
a surprise diners simply order the wine
and the chefs create a meal to go with
it our choice of vermin Tino a fruity
light slightly salty wine from Sardinia
is accompanied by black ravioli with
squid my day in Paris ends on a culinary
high note
you
you